un épais nuage de fumée visible à des
kilomètres à la ronde
l' alerte a été donnée à 21h par les
riverains de la discothèque fermé au
moment des faits les pompiers ont alors
engagé de gros moyens pour éteindre ce
feu qui n'a pas fait de victime
une quinzaine de véhicules et une
cinquantaine d'hommes au total
à notre arrivée nous avons été
confrontés à un feu sur une superficie
d'environ 3000 mètres carrés le bâtiment
était totalement embrasé ils n'étaient
pas occupés au moment du sinistre et
donc nous avons dû engager d'importants
moyens qui viennent de tout le
département et également du département
de l'aube
particularité de ce sinistre nous avons
été face à des difficultés
d'alimentation en eau on a dû au moyen
d'engins spéciaux aller chercher l'eau à
plus d'un kilomètre à la fois sur la
commune de voeux nous et deux roues vrai
mais également sur la commune des riz
afin de pouvoir alimenter au total
silence canon parce que la structure du
bâtiment s'affaissant nous n'avons pas
voulu engager personnel sur ce type d'
attaques de sinistres l'établissement le
plus gros du département venait de
changer de propriétaire
si les nuisances sonores ont pu être ses
derniers mois au coeur de débats
récurrents
les habitants des environs sont venus en
masse dès la nuit dernière
beaucoup ont été choqués face à ce
sinistre le styliste fait un peu partie
des meubles de rouvray puisque le
styliste a été construit à presque 35
ans bon même si c'est ça grandit par la
suite mais il fait partie de rouvray
donc à ce titre on peut comprendre quand
il ya un bâtiment ou à comme ça qui est
ample que les que les jambes à vienne
s'interroger et puis puis que ça leur
fasse un peu mal
les habitants de rouvray bien sûr son
sont unis ce jour devant devant devant
ce sinistre après je sais pas de quelle
manière qu'on pourra l'aider mais bon
bien sûr qu'ils sont unis les experts se
sont rendus sur place dès ce lundi matin
l'accès au bâtiment était encore très
limitée une enquête est en cours pour
déterminer les causes exactes de ce feu